I see you out here doing this but I'm
just wondering like for myself who I
watched you do this a few different
interviews I'm just wondering like what
exactly are you getting from these kind
of conversations do you find that you
yourself are learning more about people
or are you just kind of pushing an
agenda because to me like honestly I
just heard kind of like you're sticking
to the same talking points and I didn't
really hear a lot of like discussion
from your end from my end to me I just
get public opinions on stuff so I just
get people's public opinions a lot of
the reason I do what I do is I advocate
for men's rights so I have two brothers
that like committed they tried to commit
suicide so I just think the world is
harder for men than the media really
lets it be